welcome back to dc thursday everyone and
happy new year i hope you've had a great
start to your 2022.
i'm excited to continue the dc thursday
series
with you all as you know we
explore and expose the most interesting
companies tools tech
in the modern data world and
today is no exception
we have a great guest brad buddha from
census
and brad and i will chat about
operational analytics and learn a little
bit more how census
is helping data come out of the dark
ages
and is filling a missing piece in the
modern data stack
brad has exited two startups prior and
we're going to discuss the startup
lessons he learned along the way that
proceeded as becoming a co-founder of
census
we'll also chat about brad's insights on
how to find design partners for your b2b
data startup
and you'll hear how both sigma and 5tran
fit into the census founding story
so brad is a co-founder of census
previously he was an engineer at amazon
after that he started a startup called
track simple which was acquired by blue
kai
which was acquired by oracle
after that he was the co-founder of a
company called meldium which was
acquired by lagmian
and brad well i just want to welcome you
to the show thanks for joining us thanks
for having me pete i'm super excited for
our conversation today um you flatter me
uh and i'm uh i hope we can we can chat
about um
what what we're doing now with the
modern data stack and the rise of
operational analytics and um yeah the
the kind of you know curvy road to
census and what i've learned along the
way
yeah excellent well exciting exciting to
have you here and i'm sure the community
will appreciate the chat
um so i'm curious to kick things off um
tell us how you got into programming
uh so i it's funny um i
my memory of getting into programming
was uh right around you know like it was
basically time to choose a major in
college and there were a few different
things i was interested in but i had
always been the computer guy and so it
seemed pretty obvious to get the
programming and i said you know what i
think i really do want to pursue this as
you know my my first my education and
then eventually my career and my mom at
the time uh you know i was having this
conversation with her about like i think
i'm gonna gonna go you know apply to the
engineering school at michigan and try
to get into the computer science program
um and she said well yeah of course you
are and i said what do you mean and she
you know goes and digs through the the
big box of childhood drawings that every
mom has and finds the drawing that i
made when i was five or six years old of
myself and you know the teacher i or
somebody had written across the top i
want to be a computer programmer when i
grew up and she said you've always
wanted to do this uh so i'm lucky that
you know i know a lot of people you know
take take uh less direct paths to their
career their vocation or maybe are still
on those paths but i was the lucky
person who has always known what he
wanted to do and so far
knock on wood haven't regretted that
decision um and also a lot of people
have have access to computers at early
ages like um you know shout out to the
fantastic public schools in utica
michigan for putting apple twos on the
desk
you know or not in the desk but in the
computer lab and back in
1987 uh way ahead of their time yeah
yeah so so is this basic programming
early on yep i learned my first
programming was basic on an apple ii and
we got like 87 88 89 somewhere in there
when i was about seven years old like
unbelievable that a school was that
forward thinking in their curriculum at
that age like i look back at it and i'm
like wow i was lucky um yeah so learn
basic um and then kind of stuck with it
i got stuck in a basic rep for a long
time but you know through high school
learned pascal c plus um and then
eventually
a ton of other languages um but that was
sort of the learning journey for me yeah
great my first computer was a time at
sinclair in
sort of the
early
mid
80s i guess and those were the days when
the the tape drive would like screech
stuff you know
audibly um into the computer which was
the
guts of your program um so those were
man those were the days i'm not sure you
kicked me back yeah i'm not sure i ever
actually learned how the tape drive work
i feel like that was one of those things
the teacher kind of would come over and
set up for you and then you would sort
of go on with your basic environment um
i don't i don't think if you put me in
front of a computer with a tape drive i
could get it to actually not do anything
yeah those were the days yeah um and so
so you know from those early days of
being interested in computers like how
did how did the interest in data sort of
emerge over time how do you define that
yeah i think a lot of that came from
probably kind of fast forwarding a
little bit to my my first job at amazon
um so i started amazon in 2005 on the
internal kind of monitoring and
performance team if you're an amazonian
this was pmets which i gather is still
around it's kind of shockingly to me um
but you know at the time you know amazon
hat was sitting on
probably the largest fleet of just kind
of you know we didn't really call it
cloud back then but you know the data
center computers of maybe anyone outside
of the government and was generating a
lot of data and was one of you know the
first companies this wasn't totally new
but one of the first companies to
basically say um this data is all
valuable like even if it seems noisy you
can recover signal from that noise and
so let's save and capture and index and
analyze everything we possibly can
and the story of data a lot in that day
i think was like companies putting a lot
more resources into saving and capturing
than the analyzing and spelunking
but you kind of you have to do one
before the other right like you can't do
the you can't even attempt the analysis
if you've been chucking the data out the
window so i think you know that was a
big part of my indoctrination into the
importance of data was it was and that
was more about like runtime telemetry
logging data things like that you know
things that you'd see in datadog or
something like that today um but you
know i think that all of these things is
just along the spectrum i think that
it's sort of a false
barrier to say that that data is
different than business data is
different than you know operations data
or whatever it might be like i think all
of these things are as we're learning
with the modern data stack more closely
akin to each other than they are sort of
different silos
and so when when would you say you you
saw more meaningful
data analysis sort of emerge on top of
that storage right um obviously storage
became cheaper and cheaper
over time and so companies were
encouraged to store more and more data
um i guess there was a tipping point you
know somewhere along the way where
companies started to believe well oh you
know there's actually additional
analytical insights and value we can get
beyond just
you know real time um log monitoring et
cetera um do you have any perspective on
sort of when
that um sort of new data analysis you
know era started to those those those
thoughts are to take hold
yeah i think um you know i think i can
tell two versions of that story right
this sort of the industry story um and
then the you know my personal version of
the story you know i think a lot of
companies sort of got that religion in
the you know late late 2000s early 2010s
right if you think about the rise of
hadoop in the quote-unquote big data era
um that was very much like a um sort of
a decision by companies that we are
going to put resources into like
building out you know ad hoc and then
automated analysis frameworks around
these kinds of you know these pieces of
data um and you know you'd start to see
the first you know uh like to go all the
way back to the amazon story again like
the rise of personalization right even
just collaborative filtering right like
um people who bought you know people
like you bought books like this right
was like a mind-blowing idea in 2002 or
whenever they shipped that that feature
for the first time and now it's de
rigueur right like you have to have that
and it sort of just pops out of your
shopify store for free um my personal
version of that i think was you know
going back to the monitoring stack and
the data kind of internal data dog
pieces i'll call datadog um that we did
at amazon was just the
uncanny ability for these relatively
simple algorithms with given enough data
to tightly predict like what was going
to happen with the business day to day
week to week right so we had you know
that one of the main things my team's
main product was basically a graph of
orders per minute across all amazon
sites um updated with no more than five
minute latency and there were these
really tight little error bars around
that graph that showed the prediction of
where it's supposed to be and if it went
below that um obviously you would go
wake as many people up as you possibly
could if it was the middle of the night
and get everyone on deck and figure out
like we don't know why this went down
outside of our predictive band but we
believe our predictive band and like
this plus or minus five percent or
whatever it was around the
where the line is supposed to be was
shockingly good across seasonal changes
across you know weekly changes diurnal
of course like different
geographies layering over each other um
and you know
interestingly enough if the number went
above the line that was also like well
what's going on here right like oh we
had a sudden spike in orders and you
know this was the days like again this
is digging back into the deep past but
the days of harry potter books coming
out and the night that harry potter
would come out it was a big deal at
amazon because it was you know i think
it was harry potter 7 was the biggest
one that i was part of i don't remember
the name uh and it was
you know just these insane spikes in the
autograph we'd have to you know
proactively turn off the monitoring
because we knew that this was the one
thing our system couldn't handle
but um you know to go back to the story
yeah like the idea that you could put
such a tight band a predictive band
around this is what we expect to happen
in the next 10 minutes
and it would mostly happen um is
kind of revelatory for me personally of
like wow like you know simple models
with enough data can um can give you
really powerful sort of you know
actionable predictions
got it
but ultimately you decided you know
enough was enough of big companies and
you decided to move on to move into the
startup world um how did that transpire
and why did you decide to leave amazon
yeah um i wish i could say it was some
grand plan by me um but it was more of
you know the right people giving me the
right pushes at the right time so
another case in which i've been you know
fortunate in my career to have to be
surrounded by bright people and who can
sort of see like uh you know take a bet
on me but um basically my um you know i
think in the intro you said maybe i
found a track simple i was actually a
founding engineer i was not a founder so
i want to give credit to the right
people there but a couple of people i
worked with in amazon john ingles and
jeep energy
basically left track simple to say you
know hey we're doing all this cool
internal analytics stuff
there's a whole world of online
advertising of ad tech that needs this i
don't even know that we were calling it
ad tech at that point
uh and like let's build them um better
predictors better analytics on top of
their data and then that's kind of
slowly morphed into uh and this is sort
of the the foreshadowing of the rest of
my career those people don't have one
nice clean unified stream of data like
amazon does they're pulling it from a
bunch of different ad tech partners
right from from dart and dmp and or dmps
and
uh i can't remember what all the
different ad tech providers were at that
point and like you know csvs uh again
more for strataming csvs from ftp sites
about you know here's how this email
campaign performed so they the idea of
track simple and i was brought on as the
second engineer the first engineer was
actually my census co-founder anton um
but the idea of track simple was
basically let's give people a unified
dashboard with some amount of
predictions and some amount of alerts on
how their ad campaigns are going this is
primarily display ads but some email and
other things as well at that time
there was no there's no social really
and let's also bring make that unified
across several sources right like let's
allow our system track symbol to accept
data no matter where it comes from uh
and those kind of two pieces together um
i feel like have you know sort of
informed my product brain pretty
strongly throughout my career
got it
interesting
um and so like just sort of lingering on
the on the mechanics of the startup
experience um you know first of all what
what was it that surprised you most
about you know starting a company like
how is it different than
um being an engineer i mean obviously
there's there's a multitude of ways it's
different than being an engineer at
amazon but i'm curious which ones most
stood out to you
i think
it's a good question yeah there's a lot
of ways in which it's different right
and like the old joke of startup is that
you you know what no matter what your
role is you're gonna wear a lot of hats
and that's sort of you know the first
thing you learn is that you know there's
um when you're a five-person team or
what i think i was the fifth person to
join um
you
are basically like you know you're gonna
do a little bit of everything um and a
little bit of everything includes a lot
of business facing things talking to
customers understanding requirements
partner facing things right like again
you know we didn't have um because we
were sort of sitting downstream of
different data sources we didn't have a
big corporate organization where we
could sort of force our partners into a
meeting right and say like hey let's
figure out how we're gonna work together
it's more like we have to convince you
that we
together um and you know
the key thing for me and the thing that
i took away from track simple and that
early startup experience and that still
really like is probably my number one
motivator when i wake up in the morning
even today is the immediacy of being
able to connect to a customer listen to
their problem and say i have the power
to fix that sort of either directly but
like i can write some code that fixes
your problem um or sort of indirectly by
like i can you know marshal my team or
marshal my organization to make sure
that we can fix your problem um and the
incredibly fast feedback loop um you
know i i i'm blanking on on her name now
but our first customer tracked simple um
our kind of monitor with her like she
basically said you gave me my monday
back and that became the the company's
motto like you know make sure get your
mondays always get your tuesdays back i
apologize um and the idea was that like
she'd asked for something that was she
was we give her early version of track
simple um she had asked for something
that was like hey could it also do this
like you know because that would really
save me like a whole nother day of
analysis and that was like three lines
of code in our system or something like
that so we did it and her mind was blown
she's like wow i can't believe you
turned that around so quickly and it
works and you just saved me a day of my
week every week and like that ability of
software to
um just like
the leveraged power of software to
change people's day-to-day workflows and
give them superpowers um and the way
that a startup can deliver that
immediately and in like
feedback loops measured in minutes hours
or days um is the thing that keeps me
going on this kind of stuff right of
like
that we can deliver that to to our
customers and sort of get that instant
gratification like that that dopamine
hit of you know a win
yeah that's great yeah having that close
proximity to customers and users and and
being able to have that impact that can
be really
intoxicating especially when you're used
to working through layers of bureaucracy
in a larger company um
so so yeah i get it that's that's well
said
um so how did track simple end
so track simple basically um we had
a pretty good product although we had to
pivot it a couple times in terms of you
know because the ad tech landscape was
changing a lot at that point
interestingly the first version our
product was uh totally written in adobe
flash which was kind of funny um we i
think we must have been the last new
greenfield application to decide that
flash was going to be our uh runtime um
so i remember we did an early kind of
like well let's let's flip this into a
rails app which is sort of my technical
story like my first time i got to use
rails and you know a production
application um but we you know we had a
few customers who really love track
simple um but it was probably too
too narrow of a solution to be to sort
of stand on its own commercially um and
i don't want to put words too much in
the mouths of the founders because i
wasn't so much on the commercial side
there but basically you know after
raising a couple of small seed rounds it
was clear that it was going to be hard
to to sell this into big companies with
the team that we had um and blue chi was
a natural fit as an acquirer um they had
built this dmp right which is you know
for those who don't know the edtech
industry as a data management platform
basically a way that you can
uh upload um databases of your users
from a bunch of different services into
their tool and then they can go find
those people on the internet match them
and serve advertisements to them um but
what they were missing was the
performance analytics piece right like
how are these campaigns actually doing
they had some rudimentary graphs and
they had some you know they could ship
you an excel file once a week uh that
was through a fairly manual process that
was like here's how your campaigns are
doing um but the you know the appeal of
there were not a lot of things even back
then and this would have been 2008 when
we sold track simple um that we're
giving you kind of these real-time
dashboards of here's how this you know
system is performing uh by real time i
mean sort of like
less than sub-hour delay was was kind of
the area we played in um so it's a
pretty natural fit for an acquisition um
so we went over and joined the blue kai
team and continued to develop track
simple there internally um i don't know
what the ultimate disposition of the
product was but i know it lived on for
quite a long time uh within there um and
that also gave me an exposure to kind of
the database world when i joined blue
kai as an engineer that was my first
exposure to a data warehouse
which
sort of both gave me you know taught me
a little bit about
the way that world works but also gave
me a poisoned view of it because the
data warehouse we had and i don't
remember who the vendor was um i
wouldn't name and shame them anyway but
it was this thing that you racked up in
your um ingercolo and every like every
three weeks one of their techs had to
come out and take a look at it uh and
like you had to be very careful with the
queries you ran on or you could crash it
forever but like if you used it for the
right thing and sort of followed the
garden path it could just
like
chomp through tons of data super quickly
um and give you your answer um and so
that was my first exposure to data
warehousing as well was when we joined
the blueprint team and started working
on their internal data warehouse and i
actually worked on um again more
foreshadowing to census but a front end
to the data warehouse that was sort of a
query accelerator where you could run
sort of certain queries um in a in
memory database that we built like a
custom and memory database um
much faster than the raw or i shouldn't
say much faster at lower latency than
the raw data warehouse could got it yeah
well we we've reflected on the show
before um
how common this sort of pattern of
um you know modern data engineers or
startups
involved in the data space having this
sort of connection back into the ad tech
world because you know at the time ad
tech
as sort of a vertical represented
so much significant collection of data
that was sort of inordinately
larger in scale than any other you know
comparable systems of its time for the
most part and
um you know i was an engineer in new
york city and
which is sort of where doubleclick was
birthed and
um you know i i think the quality of
engineers that were comfortable working
on um high scale latency systems
that sort of came out of ad tech um you
know was was sort of um definitely left
a mark on new york city at the time
because um there were so many engineers
that you know were sort of pressed to
the brink of performance and scale
um and just sheer volume of data that
they had to process and so
there's a lot of like high quality
engineers and engineering experience and
lessons and architectures that came out
of that time and a lot of that i see has
informed um some of the architectural
systems and designs and and trade-offs
that we make even in modern data
engineering yeah i think that's totally
true i think i think that industry has
left its thumbprint on the modern data
stack in some ways right like in ways
that maybe are subtle or not totally
obvious and some of that we thought
about with the census and operational
analytics as well um and i think you
know the rise of you know
i don't know if it was google who first
pushed this or maybe doubleclick of
real-time bidding right of like you
actually need to be able to make a
decision um within a few milliseconds
about whether or not you want to bid for
this slot on this web page um really
pushed us on the performance direction
and then the last thing there like you
know and i'm sure you ran into this as
well is the inherent messiness of that
data right like that this is
and to some extent these things are
correlated the bigger the data is that
like it's going to get more
intrinsically messy um but that there's
a lot of cleaning preparation um
deduplication joining all the kind of
like bread and butter things of the
modern data stack as well that need to
be done in order to have um an
actionable stream of data come out of
those tools like that
yep yep absolutely
um well i just want to reflect for a
minute on
um the challenge that many engineers
have in finding co-founders and one of
the things about your story that's
particularly fascinating to me is how
you kind of started to pick up
co-founders along the way
a little snowball like that so you
already mentioned anton right um who i
think you originally worked with uh
amazon is that right that's correct yeah
so he and i um we're on the same team at
amazon that pmet team i think we met in
06. we weren't working on anything
together until just before we left
amazon we had started to work on um i i
believe it was called
granite then was the code name but it
basically turned into aws cloudwatch um
so we were the kind of co-leads on aws
cloudwatch um under and this was the era
when basically everything at amazon was
build this internal service as if you
are going to build an aws service um
which was a pretty like amazing vision
because i think at the time there were
only two or three aws services it was
like ec2 s3 and sqs i think was it um
and but it was still you know every
single team in the company was going to
build an aws service and they've
definitely delivered on that vision so
anton and i were co-leads on um on
cloudwatch um and then when he was sort
of pulled out of amazon to um to go work
at tracksimple uh and they asked you
know who who else should we get like who
should be engineer number two um he and
i'm grateful for this he very quickly
answered brad should be engineer number
two so that was where we went um and
realized you know you know in a startup
right you're in a small room in the you
know the modern day equivalent of a
garage this was a loft in pioneer square
sitting side by side every day for you
know between
8 and 12 hours or whatever it was that
given day and listening to the same
music and working on the same problems
and touching the same code and you bond
very quickly so that was where anton and
i first met yeah
so then um
then track simple then what happened
next because i think you
you sort of added another co-founder to
um in the next venture which if correct
me if i'm wrong became ldn as i recall
that's right yeah so um the story there
is anton and boris um my co-founder at
census and our ceo um were working
together on both of them had very
presciently determined that the iphone
was going to be a big deal that you know
once that i think it was the second or
third version of ios where the app store
opened up and they were allowing you
know non-apple stuff to run on the
iphone um they had decided that there
was going to be a gold rush um and they
were absolutely right i'm like let's
build applications and so as things were
sort of winding down with blue kai um
anton and boris had started working on a
bunch of different iphone apps and just
trying to find you know very consumery
stuff um their biggest hit
i'm going to publicly shame them here
was something called puppy pals which
was basically hot or not for dogs um and
they had you know i think a few thousand
users and i i believe anton's quote at
the time was it it earned us about a
latte a day worth of revenue um and so
they were sort of working on that and
that they got the entrepreneurial bug if
we should start something um and but
maybe you know an iphone app isn't a a
venture-backable startup um and so anton
was you know the the common thread there
between us right he said well i'm
working with this really smart guy boris
over here who used to be like an
incredibly technical pm at um at
microsoft working on visual studio and
like knew more about c plus plus than
anyone in the whole world um and i've
got this engineer brad over here who
knows how to selling some rails code um
let's let's get all three of us in a
room together and figure out what we
want to build um
and there was a long ideation phase
there um it was a lot of and i think
this is a common you know story with the
companies i found is taking a lot of
time you know working through ideas and
beating them up and i'm giving them each
of them they're due uh but one thing we
came back to um was this interesting
kind of experience i had at um blue kai
where um if you had to onboard somebody
or terminate somebody um there was kind
of a fire drill to figure out like what
do we need to add this person to or
particularly the case determination like
what do we need to get this person out
of and where are the admins for all
these tools um and that led us down the
the identity path uh which eventually
became meldium which is kind of uh
this interesting hybrid of a password
manager and a single sign-on tool um and
designed to be more accessible than the
um
kind of heavy quote-unquote heavyweight
tools like you know the leaders at the
time were basically paying identity one
log in and octa was just getting started
around that time um and we saw this as
very heavyweight and you need you know
active directory and you need an admin
and we wanted something that was light
and simple and flexible for smaller
business use cases while giving you know
80 or 90 percent of the power of a more
full-fledged idp
got it got it
well um you know not to gloss over
meldium too much but i do want to want
to get to census because that's where um
some of the data stuff comes back in
yeah um and you
basically you know collected a few more
co-founders from ldm
um
plus one you added sean right um and you
started census so
so tell us how that happened i'm sort of
like the way i like to ask the question
is what was the key insight
um that made you
want to start census or may do you need
to start census as the case may be yeah
so i think you know the the key with
census was um
i don't know that there was a eureka
bathtub moment right of like you know
this is this is the thing that we have
to build but i think it was a
combination of this long thread that i
have been pulling on anton have been
pulling on uh and boris have been
pulling on through track simple and then
through meldium of
um sas is the future um your data is
gonna exist in a lot of places um those
places are not necessarily gonna want to
talk to each other or speak a common
protocol or you know operate on a shared
service mesh or whatever it might be
so how can you be pragmatic in a sas
world about doing as much with the data
the access whatever it is that you have
um across all lots of different places
across lots of different silos so you
know we meldium was an early bet uh on
and this was you know we said when we
started melium in uh 2012 this was still
a little controversial that like sas was
going to come to rule the world that
companies were not going to run a lot of
on-prem software they were going to get
software from different vendors they
weren't going to buy everything from
microsoft or everything from oracle um
and i think of census is kind of a
logical continuation of that bet and now
like this is no longer a controversial
statement right to say that
companies are going to run on a lot of
sas and that the churn rate on that sas
is going to be high uh and you're gonna
have to move from tool to tool and
they're not necessarily gonna integrate
with each other um but you know it was
still you know an insight that we had
and something that we felt comfortable
with right gathering data from those
different tools and then um
the other half of it was just the sense
that we all have like this is you know
when
when i try to explain
what census does to you know a less
technical like relative or friend um and
who doesn't live and breathe the modern
data stack right i talk about you know
how when you call the cable company the
cell phone company the airline and
you've just been on their website and in
their app and you've exchanged emails
with them and the person you're talking
to on the phone seems to have like no
idea that you've done any of those
things that's the problem that census is
solving sort of in an indirect way which
is like
why does this company not have one
single view of what their customers are
trying to do across all of their
different data platforms
um
census you know the operational
analytics takes that in a slightly
different direction and although we do
have a lot of people using census for
customer support use cases for exactly
that
there's a lot of different ways you can
take that but the idea that how is it
that these companies who have so much
software have so much commitment to data
definitely have a desire to have a view
of their customer that is unified and or
whatever entity it might be but to use a
customer um still haven't managed to
pull that off in
then 2018 now 2022. um and what are the
missing pieces in that stack so that's
the sort of high level version of it the
very pragmatic version of that is that
sean lynch my co-founder is like the
most connected person in the entire
world and basically what he did for all
of 2017 and 2018 was knock on different
you know vps and directors and doors at
various different software companies and
say what are the problems you have with
your user data what are the problems you
have through user data until we found
this theme of um basically the missing
the missing link in the modern data
stack is kind of when we originally
pitched it
yeah and i think this is where you've
commented that it's like um you know
bringing data out of the dark pages
right to a sort of an outside observer
who hasn't been you know as
um knows the grindstone as many of us
sort of inside the data tooling stack
and you know for the last six or eight
years and and maybe sometimes
you know losing the forest for the trees
um you know coming in from the outside
it looks like it's sort of unfathomable
that some of these basic
types of data integration or as you
describe it from a business perspective
the view of the customer
just didn't really fully exist in a
holistic way and that's um that's
basically staggering um you know from
that view and it's not for lack of
trying right i think that's the key
insight like everyone wants this right
delta airlines or whoever i'm going to
pick on them because i've had to spend
some time on the phone with them lately
like it's not that they want to have
data silo it's not that they want their
their cs reps or whoever it is to be
blind to the fact that you've been
trying to interact with them they just
are lacking the tooling and i don't
think they're lacking the budgets either
they're lacking the tooling um and the
software to help them build those kind
of interconnections
um and so that was you know the big
insight and then the other thing that
came in there was just like you know
going back to the story about blue coin
data warehousing you know i had not
updated my mental model of what a data
warehouse was in the 10 years that
intervened there um and so you know when
we started casting around talking to
these companies data warehouses came up
over and over again and five trend and
other etl tools like that came up as
well and we were kind of shocked that
data warehouses had gotten good right
that they were not these um expensive
exotic uh you know pets that required
careful feeding that sat in your data
center they were elastic pay for what
you use there were a few different you
know warehouses that were all sort of
competitive with each other but across
redshift bigquery snowflake and a few
others um and that
they they were incredibly accessible
partially due to the success of the etl
space right of being able to say um or
really the elt idea that like let's just
get the data out of your sas in its
rawest purest form uh and then we'll
deal with what that means once it's all
in one place which is just like uh
absolute like lightning bolt of an idea
to me that like um
you know i'm on a digression here but
the the idea of etl right is this like
get the data out of your tool transform
it to match the destination and then
load it and the transformer to match the
destination is basically like let's wave
a magic wand at the data and make it the
right shape and that's not realistic
right like so the the elt
um philosophy of
just get the data across the wire with
perfect fidelity because it is what it
is and you can't pretend like it's not
what it is so let's get into the
warehouse and then we can deal with it
on its own terms um is a big part of of
why i think you know
this this pragmatic modern data stack
and and what eventually leads to census
and operational analytics can be
successful yep agreed
um yeah and this notion that you can
sort of in closer to real time transform
the data into whatever state you need it
to be in at that time
instead of just pre-transform it into
sort of a one-size-fits-all
schema which we know from experience and
years of systems integration doesn't
usually work anyway so i think it allows
us that flexibility um you know to sort
of defer the transformation until
a specific use case um
or format um you know is sort of made
known
yeah um
so
so one of the things i i'd like to
discuss with founders is
um how they found early customers even
even just like one step before customers
can be design partners right which is
sort of the
um
to me it's it's basically one of the
holy grails of being able to
successfully move from a ct startup to a
serious a stage startup in the b2b data
world it's
can you find design partners and early
customers and
i think this is an area where sometimes
founders especially engineering founders
because we're not always the most social
or have the biggest networks we haven't
invested in our network
over the course of our career like you
know many other business type people
have and so
you know one of one of the issues i had
as a founder early on in building b2b
stuff was you know how do you
how do you sort of solve that problem
and how do you find design partners um
tell us how you guys got unblocked at
census
yeah i think it was you know a
combination of two things like first of
all like it's 80 against sean i give him
all the credit for like being like well
networked and like being willing to do
the legwork and like to go into meetings
uh with you know in in areas where he
maybe he doesn't know the topic area
fully well and asks sort of quote
unquote dumb questions um and i mean
that in the most charitable possible way
of like you know being willing to be to
learn in a meeting and to listen and to
understand someone else's perspective of
the world um is a superpower that he has
combined with his great network and his
willingness to do the legwork that was
just like
absolutely transformative for census in
those early you know those first weeks
and months um and it also leads to a lot
of like false starts and dead ends right
like there were a lot of bad ideas that
we had that uh thank goodness we didn't
pursue um and some of them were on data
and some of them about like very remote
like uh
only only tangentially related to data
but like you know integrating different
systems for a while we were going to
build a uh i actually think this is
still a good idea if there's any
founders out there future founders
looking for one um a marketplace
oriented crm right where you could
manage both buyers and sellers on your
marketplace as different sort of
entities but have and maybe people move
between the two of them so we spent six
months or something chasing that idea
down um
but to go back to the question like a
finding design partners right like the
the lightning bolt moment was a couple
of meetings we had um and the company
that i'll name from those uh who i think
is okay with us talking about the story
is figma where they basically you know
walked us through the way that their
modern data stack works where the data
starts how it gets transformed into the
data warehouse what they were doing with
it and the last thing they wanted to do
and they basically said why can't we put
this data back into salesforce um this
shouldn't be hard and worse like
you can't like we were a little shocked
i was a little shocked as someone who's
maybe out of touch with the modern data
stack we're like
you know can't
isn't there a tool that does this or
isn't this just a few lines of code and
as i've learned now uh looking at a code
base it's not just a few lines of code
um but we said you know yeah we can we
can build that for you and we didn't
know and this is the place where you you
know i think the superpower that our
founding team has is the ability to in
parallel like write just a little bit of
code to prototype something and put it
back in front of the customer and say is
this what you wanted uh and turn that
around in the order of a few days um and
then sort of simultaneously like sell
the bigger product vision of okay now
you know if if we could do this that
means we could also of course you know
the easiest thing to do is say okay any
source in any destination it's not just
redshift two salesforce it's x to y and
okay what does any source mean does that
mean any data warehouse does it mean any
sas like you know that's there's an
interesting product line there where you
go like you know are we an ipass or are
we something else um
but to be able to simultaneously and it
also helps to have a lot of co-founders
for that matter taking you know half the
team anton and i basically um you know
hacking on like building this connection
and figuring out the right way to get
data into salesforce and the other half
the team out there selling it while it's
being built and being able to demo it in
a very raw form and be like you know
be willing to put the egg on your face
of like hey like this is a you know rail
scaffolded ui but we promise it'll look
better is this something you want um is
a great way to sort of like and you just
gotta you know like any other sales
motion you just gotta hit the pavement
and try it over and over again like you
know we had a lot of conversations with
people like that seems kind of
interesting but we had two where you
know people said yes and i like i want
you to build that and i will pay you
money for that and they were with figma
um there were a few other companies and
then five train interestingly it was one
of the first companies where um
another bit of serendipity um when we
did meldium we were in the same yc batch
as georgia taylor from five tran um
didn't really know exactly what five
trend did again my ignorance of data
tools uh but checked in with them a few
years later and we're like wow this this
is pretty cool what you guys have built
um we never would have thought to run a
data stack this way and then came back
to them when we were starting uh census
and said hey does your tool do this and
they said no and we said do people want
this they said oh yeah everyone asks us
for this and we said if if we built this
would you use it i said absolutely and
that was basically like you know that's
the strongest possible endorsement you
could get
that's great
um well it's really interesting to hear
the
the back story and sort of peel back the
the layers on
on how a company started i think it's
it's super useful
um and insightful for other engineers
who are looking to to start data
companies
of their own
um so so let's shift gears and talk a
little bit more about the tech and
architecture
behind census um i'm interested in how
you describe your product values and
um what are some of the guiding
principles you know of the engineering
team or the product team and how you've
you've shaped the product let's let's
start there and then we'll um you know
we can sort of work um more detailed uh
uh down down layers the stack from there
yeah i think i've used this word a lot i
think in our conversation today but i
think pragmatism is a big part of it
right that like um you cannot will your
data or your connections to be something
different than they are so approach them
on their own terms um and that might
mean you know building out uh you know a
different sort of surface for
integrating data into
a product analytics tool like amplitude
or mixed panel versus into a crm versus
into an erp right like those things are
different they have different facades
and let's not pretend like they're all
the same thing you know in order to gain
abstraction power you still need to
treat those you know you need to build
up some common models and a big part of
i think the first 18 months of census
was
us searching for those paradigms of you
know here are the the
the four kinds of sas applications right
or whatever that census integrates with
and it's more than that but like you
know is does this look like a relational
database does this look like an event
stream does this look like a uh like a
nosql you know style like key value bag
and sort of quickly filing you know
object services and objects within
services into into those categories
um is a big part of um basically how we
you know when we realize that hey we're
gonna need to build more than three
destinations for census it's probably
more like three hundred um let's find
the common patterns there uh and start
to build out patterns uh so i think
that's one of the product design
principles i think
um the idea that our customer is
you know
operating with an ecosystem i think is
the way i would put it right that like
um
we are not going to be the end-all
be-all tool for data integration that we
are going to integrate with other tools
whether it's you know something like dbt
for modeling whether it's you know
stitch or five trend that's bringing
data into the warehouse one of you know
the eight or nine different data
warehouses we support at this point uh
that again like the
companies
no vendor can build a full modern data i
know some have tried but i think
novender can build a full modern data
stack that comes in one box that's
turnkey and comes with all of the
connections you possibly need all of the
modeling you possibly need and a data
warehouse in it like you have to you
know sort of play in an ecosystem you
have to be a little bit t shaped um
right of like we're gonna do one thing
super super well which in our case is
reverse ctl and then a few other
supporting things at you know useful
orchestration for example in modeling
like census has a very lightweight
orchestration layer has a very
lightweight modeling layer that's good
enough for a lot of customers who i
haven't invested in a dbt or who haven't
invested in an airflow
but that if they do decide to invest in
those things that we are again an
ecosystem partner a player in that world
and that we are compatible and
integratable
mm-hmm got it
and and what about a comparison to like
a segment um how do you guys feel you
differentiate against a tool of that
kind of in that category
yeah i think the key thing for me there
is the idea of the data warehouse as um
for lack of a term a turing complete
like store for for data right a touring
complete um
programming language to the extent of
sql is a programming language for data
right so the idea i think one of the key
differentiators you know for something
like us is
it's again like pulling on that elt
thread and saying let's bring all the
data into one place and then give you a
general purpose way to reshape join
deduplicate clean up run analytics on
run you know machine learning on
whatever might be all in that one place
um and so
any tool that tries to sort of build in
an internal uh you know segment builder
point click segment builder or a you
know here's some javascript you can run
against your data or whatever like those
are all going to be inherently limited
compared to the power of sql over
massive amounts of data um so let's lean
into that like even if sql isn't the
language i would have necessarily
designed for this it's one that a lot of
people know and it runs in a lot of
places and it's like
surprisingly standardized right like i'm
actually you know we have you know
internally in the census tool we have a
little dialect engine right that's like
okay what kind of sql do i need to run
do i need to run snowflake flavored or
postgresql flavored or ms sequel
flavored or whatever and it's there's
fewer differences than there used to be
like the you know one one brand of
sequel tends to run well in a lot of
places so
that that's the degradation but the idea
that you would have a programmable
hub for your data and then once the data
is reshaped programmed in the in the
direction the the style the numbers that
you want that's the thing you'd push
back out to your destination sas
applications is i think what
differentiates us from something like
segment where it's sort of like you have
to figure out the the programming of the
shaping of your data on the fly as it
sort of goes from the source to the
destination um like just letting
everything sort of land in one place and
be at rest there and then being able to
iterate on you know through something
like dbt or even just in raw sequel on
this is what i want my model to look
like before i push it back out into the
world adds a ton of power
got it yeah and that way it's more open
than you know look ml or i mean you
don't have a
you know opinionated dsl over the top of
what you're doing um so i see how that
produces more openness and flexibility
ultimately for different kinds of use
cases yeah i think you know we've had a
lot of accidental integrations in census
because you know other tools that play
in the ecosystem um if as long as they
can speak sql or they can speak tables
um they can interact with census right
like very early on you know we just
actually launched a really like a more
sophisticated looker integration which
i'm super proud of but early on you know
people said can i use census looker and
you know go to your point and we said
well can can looker spit out you know a
table and said well i can do these
things called pdt's well then we
integrate with it like we don't need to
write a single line of code nor do they
because we're both coming into a shared
platform um and there's a lot of tools
you know great expectations in that
world and monte carlo where we don't
necessarily need to build an explicit
integration we will because you know you
can do better things with an explicit
integration but the implicit integration
if we're all going back to the same
database um adds a lot of sort of
magical kind of power
well let's talk about the the connectors
and the integrations a little bit more
because it seems like
for you to acknowledge that you know
there were many many hundreds of
integrations or connectors
um that you had to support um did that
how did that drive sort of architectural
decisions on that side of the platform
yeah i think um it's
you know i think we're slow to get there
it's one of the you know as i look at
like what things i wish i would have
realized a little sooner i wish i would
have realized that a little bit sooner
that we need to start building out those
abstractions um but the key insight and
i give full credit to anton for this
because he's driven this since the early
days of census is the idea of moving an
integration from uh um
how do you push the data in to um
i hesitate to use this words i don't
know if it's totally accurate but more
declarative style of
let me write some code a dsl in our case
in ruby that describes the capabilities
of this destination sas application um
the capabilities of its objects like
what are their primary keys what are
their foreign keys which ones are unique
what are the verbs that the uh that the
tool gives you natively right and we
have this whole long catalog of verbs
that we found there on the sas world
like there's obviously things like
insert and updated upsert but there's
way more exotic ones as well um and
various forms of merges and if i write
to this api you know what will happen
if i update a user's list of tags will
it merge with the existing list of tags
we'll overwrite them like there's all
sorts of subtlety and things like that
but then you can build the dsl to
declare them
and so basically anton you know
spearheaded that effort and now with
with our internal connectors team has
sort of like really pushed the
capabilities of that dsl to say we no
longer go write a bunch of api calls we
integrate with the service and we do but
first we write a declaration of the
services capabilities in a
census-friendly form of metadata and
then our core sync engine can take those
capabilities and take the capabilities
of the source warehouse too because not
every warehouse is created the same and
sort of you know run a compilation step
where we say okay here's the kinds of
syncs that this service can do and
here's the most efficient ways to run
those things um right like
we can actually
we're doing some rudimentary work on
even like sort of scoring those right
and saying like okay there's actually
two different ways we could sync this
data to salesforce based on the
constraints you've given us in the
configuration you've given us so let's
you know score that by performance or
let's score it by api call consumption
or whatever it might be
and pick the right one for your case
yeah it's very interesting i can see how
that that could be meaningful core ip
considering the
you know the fact that you're in the
middle and you're sort of becoming this
de facto translation
these these translation pipes for you to
have a robust
way of describing the capabilities of
apis on both the interest and the export
um you know side i can see how that
would be particularly strategically
meaningful that that must that must have
been a fun part of the system to work on
it is and it continues to be it's it's
probably the most like um you know the
capital h hard problem that we have
solved in census is that like building a
a you know or attempting to build a
unified language that that can declare
the read-write capabilities of a bunch
of different apis and a bunch of
different systems
and it's not perfect and the great thing
is you know you can always eject down
into raw code and say well this one
doesn't this one doesn't play with the
the declaration system so you know this
service will just get a regular
connector um and that means that you
know we can shipping those connectors is
maybe more expensive for us but it's
still doable and we can still do with
the same capabilities um so that's the
nice thing about uh doing that in sort
of a going way back to the the idea of
ruby and the internal dsl where it's you
know it's just ruby code
yeah very cool
um so are there other architectural
trade-offs that you felt you had to make
as you were
building the system or tell me about
something that might be sort of a
surprising architectural decision that
you guys may have made
um
i don't know if this is this counts for
surprising or not but one thing i think
of that you know i'm pretty proud of
that we've built um that is to build
census in a very recovery oriented
manner and i don't know if this term is
used a lot much anymore but this was a
big term in the kind of distributed
systems world in the early 2010s this
idea of recovery oriented computing um
people who've lived in in the erlang or
elixir world will very much be familiar
with this this idea that like um
you divide some tasks into logical
pieces of work and any of those pieces
of work can fail at any time and instead
of sort of trying to fix the failure
like crash it and move on and do it
again right and so like finding building
a sync engine um you know some of the
the largest data
sinks that can run in census i think the
longest one we run took 17 days and
that's not because census is slower
because the data warehouse is slow it's
because it's you know 10 billion records
or whatever it was in that customer's
case moving into um a system that can
only write you know a couple thousand
per second right i can't remember the
exact numbers but sort of do the math
there um and we sort of eyeballed this
and said well this is going to take 17
days to run um you know if we if we nail
it uh and during that 17 days a lot of
things are going to crash right like
just because we are we're going over the
internet we're talking to apis that we
don't control those things spew out 500s
for no good reason or you know if you're
lucky they speed out a 500 if you're
unlucky they just sort of don't answer
your connection and
you know leave it open and never return
a response
so let's start we'd already sort of you
know decomposed our sync engine into
logical steps right more for reporting
and analytics and telemetry but starting
to treat those steps as units of failure
as hierarchical units of failure and you
know sort of if part of the hierarchy
fails you just checkpoint and retry from
there and then figuring out there's some
subtlety to which kinds of retries are
safe and which are not um but most of
them you know most of the time we're
dealing with item operations that are
safe to retry and we can sort of
checkpoint and move on so we put a big
you know investment right around two
years ago uh when census was first
starting to see it's really like you
know higher scale customers into
building out a reasonable recoverable
sync engine that could just sort of pick
up from any failure and keep pressing on
um and that's been a really important
part of our sort of tech stack is like
yeah again the insight there is like if
you get an error basically crash right
and like let your supervisor decide what
to do don't try to handle errors for the
most part
got it well that's your version of
failing gracefully and um you know that
makes a lot of sense
yeah
um so tell us about i mean to the extent
that you're that you're open to sharing
um what are some other features in your
roadmap that you're particularly excited
about like what's coming down the pipe
for census yeah i think um a lot of what
you know now that customers have been
using census you know some of our oldest
customers have been says this in
production for almost three years now um
and a lot of them have been on it for
you know a year or two they're starting
to do richer things they're starting to
do multiple destinations and bring
different teams into it um so there's a
lot of things around like how do we how
do teams collaborate with incenses that
we're excited about i don't know if i
can talk about any specific features yet
but you know how
if you have a data engineering team
that's providing models and you have
a sales operations team that's you know
consuming that for crm and then a cs
team that's consuming that to power you
know their zendesk or whatever their
their cs tool or customer success tool
might be um how can those teams all work
together on the same data um
is an interesting area for us to to kind
of pursue because we are a place um i
think good software tools do this where
different teams come together to
collaborate right like they have a
shared set of you know nouns and verbs
they can talk about together um so
that's one area i'm excited about is
like what we can do to help make
collaboration better with consensus and
help sort of uh you know one of the
things that uh i'm not sure if this is
shipped yet or not but if it hasn't it
will ship very soon like the idea for a
data team to sort of bless a particular
model is saying this is ready for
production this is ready to be synced
versus this one is a draft simple stuff
but like workflowy things that um make
collaboration a lot easier and more
explicit than implicit um so that's
that's one exciting area and then i
think the the bigger picture that we're
sort of tackling this year is you know
we
the data space has been like it's a lot
of early adopters which is great um who
are like you know they know a lot about
their stack they know a lot about you
know their data down to the rows of
columns and they know a lot about the
fields and the semantics of the
destinations and so if you know what you
want to do with data and you know how to
do it census is a great tool for you if
you know what you want to do with data
but you're not exactly sure how to do it
right now we you know we use our sales
engineering our customer data architects
to help you do that but like moving some
more of that into the product is
something we need to do as well is like
i want to follow a pql motion i want to
follow a you know customer support you
know ticket scoring experience like um i
know what data i have i know more or
less in a flowchart sense like how i
want this to work out but i might not
know the details of how that interacts
with the zendesk api you know even
though we sort of abstract that from you
like you're still seeing the artifacts
of that in the census tool so i think
giving people a higher level abstraction
in a way that you know people who are
systems thinkers who are sharp and like
they get it and they know exactly what
they want to happen they just don't like
they don't live and breathe sass apis
a more accessible version of the census
tool um is a really important thing for
us this year is
great
well brad um you know it's been great
chatting with you um we're pretty much
out of time but i did want to ask you a
last question before we let you go and
that's essentially
what surprised you most about your work
in the data ecosystem so far
um
it really is a community more than i
would have guessed right like it's it
really interesting to me to the extent
to which and like a ton of props to the
team at dbt for like building their
their slack and their community because
i think they've headed this um but
there's a lot of other great communities
as well but like the you know the extent
to which people are willing to share
best practices to collaborate to sort of
jump in and help with someone else's
problem that might not even work at your
company just for sort of like you know
the
the the kudos the karma whatever it is
of like you know giving back um is
really heartening um it's like you know
clearly this is a group of people who
sees the world in a different way than
we saw before and they want to spread
that mantra um and that the fact that we
get to be a small part of that is
humbling and pretty awesome um
and yeah i think it's really cool how
you know so much of our sales has been
you know even for a small company like
you know organic through those through
those channels right like where someone
will say well i'm using census to do
this and someone else will say what's
census what's operational analytics
what's reverse ctl um and that starts a
conversation um and that's you know i
think a lot of credit also too to our
team for like really making our first
cohort of customers incredibly happy and
making them all promoters um that's you
know
this is not new startup advice but again
like if you are a founder or you're
going to be a founder right like there
is nothing you could do more than to
make those incredible those first
customers incredibly happy and
incredibly like you know promoters of
your tool um like a thousand people have
said it before but i'll say it again um
and so that like the degree to which
things move through communities in in
the modern data stack and in this world
um
is it not something i would have
expected i thought we'd be doing a lot
more of having you know
we have done some awesome marketing and
i'm really proud of our team for doing
that but i thought we'd be having to do
a lot more of
preaching the gospel ourselves and then
you realize the extent to which our
customers and our partners be preaching
possible for us
yeah that's that's awesome well um we're
excited to have
census be part of data council austin
which is coming up and
to join the data community there um so
we're extremely excited about the irl
event coming up and it will be great to
have you guys participate and folks can
um you know wait and chat with you there
or i'm sure there's other
more digital ways that they can reach
out to you what's the best way for
someone to to get in contact if they
want to learn more about census or
maybe even ask for your advice on on
their data startup
totally um let's see so a few ways you
can like um
best ways to reach me probably are
twitter um so i'm at bradley buddha um
if you sort of like less you know you
know you want help with a startup or an
idea or like hey what is this modern
data stack thing what is this
operational linux thing like help me
understand that i'm happy to like you
know answer questions there um and then
like a shout out to our own community
the operational analytics community if
you go to getcensus.com you can find uh
i should know this but it's one of the
pages i think it's right there on the
homepage to join the operational
analytics community and we have a really
active slack there that's you know
obviously around you know centered
around operational analytics but has a
lot of cool side conversations there as
well um that's a great place to jump in
to learn more about the product um if
you're not yet you know
what maybe you're maybe you're looking
to buy census or a tool like it and you
want to understand how they work or
maybe you just want to learn how this
world works and how you can sort of get
involved in it that's a great place to
come as well so those two my twitter and
operational analytics community
great excellent yeah thank you for
sharing those i'm sure folks will um
find you there
cool well thanks brad um it's been great
to chat with you i hope to see you in
person soon yeah i hope to see you as
well pete and thanks for um you know
taking this time with me and we're
excited to be part of data council and
here coming up soon yeah excellent
and to the rest of our listeners um
thanks for joining us uh next week we'll
have uh another interesting episode of
dc thursday with sumitab mitra from
rudder stack
another important player in the space so
don't forget to
hit your youtube notification bell so
that you get notifications about the
next event
you can find all of our previous dc
thursday episodes also on youtube
in a convenient playlist which we'll
post in the chat
and otherwise we're looking forward to
seeing you all in person soon
thanks again for joining us and and
we'll see you next time